[Música]
[Aplausos]
se puso género las profesiones
TESAVEL
porque eso no
vas a salir que me dediqué a estudiar a
leer asesorarme a charlar
no encontré un solo nombre responsable
de esta definición histórica
docencia carrera sociales
femenina
mecánica construcción tecnología
ingeniería
masculina
vas a salir la novia brecha que nos
separa del hombre está temática parece
haberse definido por decantación
Decepticon los crían diferenciando el
género mostrándonos que todo sea está
hecho para los nenes y las nenas lo
celeste para esos
la rosa para nosotras
un videojuego para eso
una Barbie para nosotras
yo me crié con cuatro hermanos varones
la única mujer y la más chica se
imaginarán lo masculino que era mi casa
durante las tardes mis hermanos se
juntaban a jugar a los videojuegos
tiros guerra auto fútbol todos muy para
eso sería mi abuela
porque todos tuvimos una abuela o
alguien de nuestro entorno muy
tradicional que ese chico no se iba
contando que era para eso y que para
nosotras
yo amaba los videojuegos de carrera de
autos
y de vez en cuando cuando mis hermanos
estaban de buenas pero estaban
y un día me encontró mi abuela se me
acerco y me dijo nena le vamos a decir a
mamá y a papá que te compren un
videojuego de princesas estos no son
para vos
vamos a jugar que la abuela te preparo
la masa con harina y agua
eso si podían poner toda su imaginación
creatividad jugar a los videojuegos y yo
tenía poner toda mi creatividad en la
harina y el agua
un poco injusto no creen
eso les propongo
el juegos no tengan género
los prejuicios los preconceptos las
convenciones que surgen en la familia de
que somos chiquitos
no se van a pensar de una manera que
puede influenciar y hasta perjudicar
nuestra elección de vocación
le viene la gran pregunta
qué quieres ser cuando seas grande
inocente recuerdos a pregunta resonando
sobre mi cabeza durante mucho tiempo
estamos de acuerdo que es una pregunta
muy simple 6 palabras y para ahora sin
objetivo de daño
pues no me digan que no fue la primera
vez que se sintieron en hacker
por eso sí
claro tras años de haber recibido
juguetes orientados a la docencia al
maquillaje al baile a la cocina
imaginarme siendo desarrolladora de
videojuegos no me iba a salir muy
espontáneamente
y ahí nuevamente aparece alguien de
nuestro entorno pero se empieza a
explicar que querrás que no son para
nosotras
un discurso silencioso y muy arraigado
que nos dice eso es más de hombres
personas quiero contar sobre algunas
mujeres
quiero saber si las conocen
si eso le digo Emily Rowling saben quién
es
Margaret Hamilton
Ada Lovelace
Elisa Bachofen
dos décadas antes de que se recibiera la
primera mujer ingeniera en Estados
Unidos Emily Rowling supervisó una de
las obras más extraordinarias de Nueva
York y Puente de Brooklyn
Margaret Hamilton
diseño el software que llevo el hombre
en la Luna
Ada Lovelace fue la primera persona que
programo
Elisa Bachofen fue la primer mujer
recibida de ingeniera en Argentina en
1009 18
cuántas Emily's margaritas elisas hadas
hay atrás
cuántas Marías Teresas susanas se
quedaron en el camino queriendo estudiar
estas carreras pero no se animaron a
romper con estos estereotipos este
discurso silencioso las termino
convocando hacía otro camino
pero estoy se imaginan que sería de la
tecnología con la creatividad femenina
de las matemáticas con el ingenio
femenino
si lo imaginamos y lo sabemos porque
muchos de los descubrimientos que se
hicieron en la historia fueron hechos
por mujeres
mujeres que se animaron a romper con
estos paradigmas mujeres que no solo
fueron grandes por sus acciones
fueron grandes porque se animaron a
decir yo quiero yo puedo
y si por casualidad
nos imaginábamos como grandes ingenieras
desarrollando soluciones
seguramente y sin malas intenciones
no se ven a pensar que esas carreras no
son para nosotras
o lo que sea aún más triste
quiero seríamos competentes frente al
hombre en ese rubro
ante estas negativas imaginaran que no
hay muchas chicas que elijan este camino
entonces creo que como sociedades
avanzadas y en pleno auge deberíamos
reflexionar
que para que los niños y niñas tengan
plena libertad de esos futuros las
carreras no deberían estar tenías de
construcciones sociales alrededor del
género
y así si el abanico de oportunidades
sería muchísimo más amplio tanto para
esos como para nosotras
esto no es tan fácil
porque aún hoy seguimos enfrentando
barreras que nos impiden acceder a las
carreras masculinizadas a que nos
animemos a estudiar las carreras
masculinizadas entonces creo que es muy
importante que desde chicos nos cuenten
historias diferentes
pero los Márquez nuestra capacidad
diferenciándola con la de nombre
que no restrinja nuestros sueños
simplemente nos dejen imaginar soñar sin
ponerle género a una profesión a un
sueño
esto es tan importante que tiene que
empezar en las escuelas
las escuelas tienen que enseñarnos a que
nos animemos a romper con estos
paradigmas también los tienen que contar
que las carreras no tienen género y que
nosotras las mujeres
podemos hacer todo
con toda libertad al igual que los
hombres
Raúl es difícil
y esto no es solo competencia un padre
con una hija
esa competencia de todos porque todos
traemos estos Sejos que nos quitan
libertad de diálogo libertad de
pensamiento libertad de acción
todos hombres y mujeres
tenemos filtros o marcos que los
predeterminan eso no es libertad
Tejina ni propia
posesión papá
o alguien de nuestro entorno no quiera
acompañar
en nuestra elección de vocación que nos
de plena libertad
y luego a Sincelejo sin
condicionamientos por eso los invito a
que todos revisemos estas viejas
costumbres
si a mí me gustan los videojuegos
debería haber sido fiel a mí misma
y la tecnología
es una brecha de género
si una más creo que es la tecnología
para qué sirve
la tecnología sirve para resolver
problemas de manera rápida y eficiente
efectiva es un conjunto de herramientas
de procesos de acciones que no sé si la
vida más fácil
pero analicemos
sigue así la vida más fácil a todos o no
porque si no es universal no es
equitativa
hace más de 200 años que el mundo no
atravesaba cambios sociales económicos
sanitarios y tecnológicos tan bruscos y
profundos
sin duda la pandemia acelero en un año
lo que podríamos ser devorado una década
no es tecnología se hicieron presentes
otra se democratizaron pero las viejas
desigualdades continuaron tan renovadas
como las nuevas tecnologías
los estereotipos de género pusieron a
los hombres como los protagonistas de
las carreras tecnológicas
de hecho es uno de los sectores con
menor participación femenina
me quiero detener y compartirles unos
datos
tú sabían que solo el
33% de las inscriptos a las carreras
stem en la ciencia la matemática la
ingeniería y la tecnología son mujeres
si nos enfocamos solo en tecnología
16 de cada 100 mujeres eligen este
camino
y hacía 50 años que las mujeres eligen
más estas carreras eran mucho más sobre
el porcentaje de mujeres que elegían
este camino
pero pokémons en Argentina
relacionemos género con ingeniería y los
números son un poco peligrosos
en los últimos años se gradúa un
ingeniero cada 3000 hombres
una ingeniera cada 10.000 mujeres
uno cada
3001 k10000 y esto sucede porque los
estereotipos de género afectan la
confianza de las mujeres nosotras aún
hoy seguimos enfrentando barreras que
nos impiden acceder al mercado laboral
al chip
la que si ingresan se encuentran en
condiciones salariales y promoción
profesional menores a la de esos
lo cual por supuesto Profundis a las
desigualdades socioeconomicas
nosotras las mujeres no nos sentimos tan
atraídas por estas carreras como los
hombres y la consecuencia de esto es que
los puestos como las carreras
tecnológicas terminan siendo
masculinizadas
estoy sabían que solo el 6% de las
aplicaciones móviles desarrolladas a
nivel mundial fueron hechos por mujeres
le estamos más mujeres más mujeres que
se animen a crear tecnología
más mujeres que sean parte de esa mesa
de toma de decisión tecnológica
no debería importar el género a la hora
de elegir una profesión y trabajar en
esa
y todos somos responsables
hombres mujeres jóvenes y adultos
la tecnología no para de avanzar
y si nosotros seguimos sin despertar
vocación en niñas
nosotras las mujeres no vamos a tener
plena libertad de elegir los trabajos
del futuro
José 7 años que trabajo en tecnología y
por supuesto no le he una carrera
tecnológica de base religiosa social
pero el día que entre lo vi todo
tecnología igual hombre
pero muy difícil cruzarse con mujeres
pasillos repletos de hombres reuniones
masculinizadas
y lo peor de todo toma de decisión por
un solo género
hoy es muy difícil contratar mujeres que
se han animado a subirse barcos y sean
parte del mundo de la innovación
pero estamos más mujeres estamos más
oportunidades para mujeres en tecnología
no le pongamos género los juegos no le
pongamos género a las profesiones las
sociedades deben funcionar con ambos
géneros y así vamos a lograr un mejor
mañana
porque la inclusión siempre pero siempre
nos va a beneficiar a todos muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]